hmm hey other one
my name is Malta this was this were the
nested loops who performed last year at
Jes come for you you should check out
the video it's amazing so many
JavaScript funds in 3 minutes of music
yeah by the way I'm crying forcing the
internet I don't really want to go into
why that's the case and there's another
important fact about me I used to build
very large JavaScript applications I
don't actually do that anymore so I
thought it was like a good kind of time
to give a bit of a retrospective and
share what I learned yesterday I was
having a beer and I was asked like hey
Malta so what actually gives you the
right authority to talk about this topic
and I was actually gonna talk about that
anyway because I think it's a bit on
topic usually I think talking about
yourself is a bit weird so I built this
JavaScript for America at Google and
it's used by photos sites plus Drive
play and the search engine and like all
these projects right so I guess but some
of them are pretty large you might have
used a few of them and this javascript
firm work is not open source which is
sad I guess but I think there's some
relevant things to be learned and the
reason why it's not open source is
because the kind that came out at the
same time is reacting I was like do we
really need another JavaScript framework
like Java like Google has a few of those
right there's like angular and polymer
and I just thought it would confuse
people and I was like well just keep it
to ourselves but I don't think that's
actually all that that's not what this
talk is about anyway so I just have some
stuff and I think it's generally
applicable so let's talk about very
large application what do they have in
common so certainly that you might have
a lot of developers right so it might be
like a few dozen or so and so because
there's no humans humans have feelings
and if problems and you have to factor
that in and even if your team is not as
big maybe you're working on that thing
for a while and maybe you're not
actually the first person working on
this you might not have all the context
that might be stuff that you don't
really understand there might be people
now on your team that don't understand
everything that's in the application
so that's kind of what we have to think
about when we want to build these very
large applications that have maybe
different properties from us from a
smaller one
and another thing I wanted to do here is
to give that a bit of a context in terms
of everyone's careers so I think many of
us here in the room would maybe consider
themselves a senior engineer or we're
not quite there yet but we want to
become one and I think that's what that
means is you know as a C engineer I kind
of think that I would be able to almost
solve every problem that someone soft
throws at me right I kind of know my
tools and I know my domain and you know
I can I can do things and the other
important part of that job is that I
make the junior engineers on my team be
senior engineers but what what happens
is that at some point we wonder like
what might be the next step we've
reached that seniority stage what is the
next thing we're going to do and so for
some of us the answer might be
management but I don't think that should
be the answer for everyone because not
everyone should be a manager right like
some of us really great engineers and
why don't we do that for the rest of our
lives so I want to propose a way to kind
of level up a bit of Buffett's in senior
level so the way I would talk about
myself as a senior engineers that I say
like I know how I would solve a problem
right and because I know how I would
solve it I could also teach someone else
how to solve the problem and so my my
theory is that the next level is that I
can say about myself I know how others
would solve the problem let's make this
a bit more concrete so you make that
sentence I can anticipate how the API
choices that I'm making or the
abstractions that I'm introducing in a
project how they impact the way other
people would solve a problem I think
this is a fundamentally like powerful
concept that allows me to to reason
about how the choices are making in
software design how they impact the
implication and I would also call this
an application of empathy right so
you're thinking with other stuff
engineers and you're thinking about how
what you do and the api's that you're
giving them how they impact how they
write software right luckily this is
empathy on easy mode because you know
empathy generally it's hard and this is
still very hard but at least the people
that you're having empathy with there
are also other software developers or
other software engineers and so while
they might be very different from you
they at least have in common that they
you know building software and and I
think that this is something you can get
quite good at all right so thinking
about these topics there's one very
important term we're going to talk about
which is the programming model so which
is the word that I'm going to use a lot
which means like given a set of API s or
set of libraries or set of framework set
of tools
how do people write software in that
context and so my talk is really about
how subtle changes in API is and so
forth how they impact the programming
model I want to give a few examples
about things that impact the program
model right so let's say if your angular
project and you're saying like no I'm
gonna pop this to react that is awfully
going to change where people write
software right but then you're like ah
you know sex the kilobyte for like this
Dom de thing that seems reasonable let's
switch to pre act and that's an API
compatible thing it's not going to
change the way people write software
just because you make that choice maybe
then you're saying like oh this is
really complex I should have liked
something orchestrating how much
vacation works I'm gonna introduce Redux
that is going to change how people write
software you're then getting this
requirement we are needing a date picker
and you're going to NPM you search for
date picker there's 500 results you pick
one doesn't really matter which one you
pick will not change how you write
software but having npm at your
fingertips
this vast like you know collection of
modules having that and being able to
use it in your application it does
change how you write software cool yeah
so these are just a few examples about
like things how you can impact the way
people write software now I want to talk
about one aspect that all large
JavaScript applications have in common
when you deliver them to users which is
that a venture
they will get so big that you don't want
to like deliver them all at once and for
this which kind of all introduced this
technique called code splitting what
code splitting means is that you define
a set of bundles for your application so
he's saying like you know me you some
users to use this some users use that
let's put like a bundle together and I'm
only going to load that bundle if the
function of the application that the
user is actually using is being executed
and that's something that every one of
us can can do like many things it was
invented by closure compiler at least in
the JavaScript world but I think the
most popular way of doing code splitting
is with a pack and if using for example
objects which is super awesome they just
recently a few weeks ago added support
for this so definitely something y'all
should do but there are some things to
think about when you introduce this to
an application because it does have
impact on the programming model you have
things that used to be sync they now
become async so without code splitting
the application is nice and simple it's
one big thing it starts up and then it's
stable and you can assume stuff about
you can reason about it you don't have
to wait for stuff with code splitting
you might sometimes say oh I need that
bundle so you know needs to go to the
network and you have to affect your in
that this can happen and so your
application becomes more complex also we
have humans entering the field because
Co splitting requires you to like define
bundles and it requires you to think
about when to load them so these humans
engineers on your team they have to now
make the decisions what is going into
which bundle and one to load that bundle
right and every time you have a human
involved that definitely impacts the
program model because now they have to
think about it now there is one very
established way that solves the problem
that gets the human kind of out of this
mess when doing code spinning which is
called route based code splitting and
that is my like if you don't do it yet
that's probably the way how you should
do it as a first cut so routes are like
the the baseline URL structures of you
okay
so my for example in you might have all
your product pages on slash product
slash and some IG and you could category
pages somewhere else right and so your
router in your application now
understands there's code splitting and
whenever you go to a road the router
loads the code and then within that
route you can forget about Co splitting
existing right now you're back to the
programming model that was almost the
same as if you had just one big bundle
for everything all right so it's a
really nice way to do this and
definitely a good first step however the
talk title is designing very large
JavaScript applications and they're so
large that sometimes a single route
bundle might not you know be feasible
anymore because those those routes
itself get to fit very big I actually
have a good example for for an
application that's big enough so I was
like figuring out how to be a public
speaker coming up to this talk and I get
this like nice list of blue things right
and you could totally envision this page
to be like super wealth you know fitted
for for route based code splittings like
search slash and there's this list of
stuff and it's not very complicated but
then I wasn't I kind of wondering what
the weather was because California kind
of had a bit of a cold one and so I was
searching over there was Simpsons
suddenly there was completely different
different module right and so this
seemingly simple route of slash search
is more complicated and we thought and
then I was getting invited to this
conference super exciting and I was
checking out how much you know US
dollars are in one Australian dollar and
there's this you know complex currency
converter and so again I think it's
obviously there's like a thousand
special ones of these right and so it's
infeasible to say we're going to put all
of them in one bundle because then that
bundle is gonna be like a megabyte and
people are going to be unhappy so we
can't do it that way we have to come up
with a different way of doing it now no
route based coding was nice because it's
a very coarse grain level of your
application at the very highest level
you make that split everything under I
could ignore
because I like simple stuff if you don't
do the super course one how about the
super fine-grained version right let's
think about what would happen if we
laser loaded every single component of
your website that seems really nice from
a like efficiency point of view when you
only think about bandwidth right it
might be like Superbad from other point
of views like latency but it is a nice
way of doing it and and and want to
consider but let's imagine for example
your application users react in react
components statically depend on their
children right and that means that if
you stop doing that because you start
lazy loading your children then it
changes your program model and things
stop being so nice so let's say you have
a Currency Converter component that you
want to put on your such page
you import it right that's like the
normal way of doing it in your six and
that's pretty nice but if you want to
lazy load it you get code like this
where you like use dynamic import with
just a new fancy thing to like lazy load
your six modules and you wrap it into
some load all the component and you know
there's probably like 500 million
different ways to do this and I'm
certainly not a reactive program or even
anywhere to expert but like it's
definitely going to change how you write
the application and and that's no longer
it's nice because stuff you know it's
more complicated something that was
static no its dynamics that's another
red flag for the program we're all
changing
you have to suddenly wonder who decides
what to lazy load when because that's
going to impact the latency of your
application the human is there and
they're like they're static import this
dynamic import when do they use which
it's also really bad if you do it wrong
because one static import is going to
like make everything be together again
and you don't really get any benefits
from dynamic loading so that's really
complicated and it's going to go wrong
when you have a lot of Engineers over
long periods of time I'm going to talk
about like how Google actually does it
and what one way is to achieve like a
good programming model with good
performance and hopefully good results
so what we're doing is
we take our component we split it by
rendering logic the sort of way we
render it and the logic of like for
example on the currency converter what
happens when you press the button and
you get you know use the two Australian
dollars so we we have these two things
instead of one thing and then we only
load the logic of a page when we
actually rendered the component and and
that again is a very simple model
because now we can just service at
render a page and then whatever we kind
of actually rendered because you
searched for whether and there was a
better module then that rendering of the
weather module triggers the client to
load the code and again that kind of
puts the human out of the conversation
we get that you know Australian dollar
answer and we have a very simple page
now this might that might seems nice
but it does have some trade-offs right
so if you know how server-side rendering
typically works with frameworks like
react of UJS or so forth what they do is
a process called hydration the way
hydration works is you server-side
rendering something and then on the
client you render it again which means
you have to have load the code to render
something that's already on the page
which is incredibly wasteful both in
terms of loading that code and in terms
of executing it right so it's a bunch of
wasted bandwidth as a bunch of basic CPU
but it's really nice because because you
can ignore on the clients that that
these servers I wondered something right
and that is very nice and so if you
design this very large application you
have to think about do I want to take
that super fast route but it's more
complex or am i okay with the hydration
approach which is less efficient but
it's so nice for programmers right and
so you will have to make this decision
nobody can help you with that
cool my next topic is my favorite
problem in computer science which is not
naming things although I probably gave
this a bad name and it's not off-by-one
errors
it's the 2017 holiday special problem
who here has ever like written some code
and now it's no longer needed but it's
still on your code base right so maybe
there was a 2017 holidays party special
or something like that right um so this
happens I think see this particular
famous for it if you have this one big
CSIS file and there's a selector in
there but who really knows that that
still matches anything in your
application you know so you cannot just
keep it there and so I think that's
community it's at the forefront of a
revolution because they realize this is
a problem and they created solutions
like CSS nsj right we have a single file
component the 2017 holiday special
component and you like say okay it's not
2017 anymore we can delete this one
component and then everything is gone
and it's very simple so very easy to
delete code so I think this is a very
big idea and it should be applied to
more than just CSS so when I give a few
examples of this like general idea that
you want to avoid central configuration
of your application at all costs because
central configuration like having
central CSS file makes it very hard to
leak code so I was talking before about
routes in your application so many
application will have a file like routes
GS which is all your routes and then
those routes met themselves to like some
broad component right and that's an
example of central configuration it's
something that you do not want in a
large application because now like some
engineer says do I still need tech what
component they're like I need to update
that file but that's like kind of owned
by some other team or something like
that I'm like too scared to do it and
I'm maybe I'm going to do that tomorrow
or like maybe I don't do it at all right
and so this file it's more like you know
it's edition only people don't tend to
get rid of stuff another example of this
anti-pattern is the web pack config
dutchy is where you have this one thing
let's assume to build your entire
application and that you know might go
fine for a while but eventually you know
needing to know about every aspect of
what some other team did system where
all right that just doesn't scale so
again I think we need a pattern that has
to emerge how to decentralize configure
stuff that we want to build it's not
only bad examples there's good examples
so for example package of JSON
vamped npm right each package says I
have these dependencies this is how you
run me this is how you built me and
obviously not like there's not this one
giant configuration file of all of NPM
because that would not work right you
would you imagine having a hundred
thousand modules and you all would have
to edit as one file would definitely
give you a glut of merge conflicts and
get right and and so sure NPM is very
big but I would argue that many of our
applications you know while they're not
as big as NPM they get big enough that
we have to worry about the same stuff
and we have to kind of adopt the same
patterns so I don't really have like all
the solutions but I think this you know
this idea that Jesus and Jes brought to
the table it's going to come to other
aspects of how we build applications
more abstractly I would describe this
idea that we take responsibility for how
our application is designed in the
abstract how it's organized as taking
responsibility of shaping the dependency
tree for replication and with dependency
on that now I mean that's like very
abstract like it could be like you know
yes six module dependencies could be
data dependency service dependencies
there's many ways to have dependencies
so obviously you know we all have like
super complicated applications but I'm
going to have a very simple one it has
only four components there's a router
that kind of knows how to go from one
aspect of your application to the next
and it has a few word components a B and
C now as I mentioned before this is the
central import problem right because the
router now has to import all the work
components and you know if you want to
delete one of them you have to go to the
router you have to delete the import if
to delete the road and so forth and that
eventually and you with the holiday
special 2017 problem Wow yeah so we have
at Google come up with a solution for
this that I want to introduce to you
which I don't think we've ever talked
about it's kind of cool we invented a
new concept it's called enhance and it's
something you use instead of import and
in fact it's the opposite of import it
is a reverse dependency so if you
enhance a module you make that module
have a dependency on you which you know
it seems kind of cool so looking at the
Pennsy graph what happens is that
there's still the same components but
they the error is no point in the
opposite direction right so instead of
the router importing the the route
components the work components announce
themselves using enhance to the rotor
the rock component a says hi router here
am please have a dependency on me
instead of the opposite to rate right
and that now means that I can just get
rid of the Road component a by deleting
the file and because you know it no
longer enhances the router that's the
only operation have to do to delete this
component and that's really nice it
wasn't for the humans to now have to
like think about hmm I have like import
of it enhance which one do I use under
which circumstances right and so they
they suffer from this and I think this
is a particularly bad case of this
because imagine just how dangerous it is
that you as a programmer I get the power
to make everyone else every file in the
system have a dependency on you it's
easy to imagine that this leads to
really bad situations so Google we
decided it's a nice idea but we make it
illegal no one gets to use it one
exception which is generated code it's a
really good fit for generate code
actually and it solves some of the
problems that generated code has which
is also really nice
so with generated code sometimes you
have to import if generate file they
can't even see you have to guess it's
name is really unpleasant if that
generated file is just there and the the
shadows and enhance that's some central
entity then you don't have these
problems right you don't you never have
to know but this file it just magically
enhances the central registry and so
that works really well let's take a look
at a concrete example so we have our
single file component here and we run a
code generator from it and we kind of
extract this little route definition
file for example maybe use like some
static declaration and you're saving a
file component we parse it out using our
some Harry Potter ast and then we have
that route file right
and that route file just says hey router
um please enhance me and and that's how
it works and obviously you can use this
pattern for like all kinds of other
things when you're using like graph QL
or like some other thing like that and
you're saying hey my data dependency the
router should know about it and you're
doing the same pattern maybe of some
services whatever right like whatever
fancy words you have in computer science
um so you can you can use this pattern I
think it works really well it's really
powerful and I think it has a good
feature all right
um fortunately this is not everything we
need to know about it there's a second
favorite problem in computer science
which all I call the base bundle pile of
trash so the base bundle in your like
graph of bundles of the application it's
the one bundle that whatever you do
whatever the user is doing you will
always load this one bundle and so it's
particularly important because if it's
big then everything you'll do is big
right if it's really small then you can
have really small dependent bundles
right still anecdote I at some point
joined the Google+ Callister
infrastructure team and I found out that
the base one had eight hundred kilobytes
of JavaScript and so my warning to you
is if you want to be more successful in
Google+ don't have a charge kilobytes of
JavaScript in your base bundle and
unfortunately this is very easy right to
get to a bad state I'm going to show you
a few examples so again your base bundle
it needs to like to depend on the routes
because you always want to know when you
go from A to B what is the route for B
right so it has to be there but what you
really don't want is any form of UI
because depending where the user comes
in there might be different UI so you
really don't want that UI to be there
right and so know the date picker it
definitely should not be in your date
base bundle right the checkout flow
should not be in your base bundle and so
how do we prevent that right
unfortunately imports are very fragile
you might like innocently import that
cool util package
right because it has a function to make
random numbers and now someone says I
won't need a utility for self-driving
cars and suddenly you are like import
the I don't know machine learning
algorithm for self-driving cars and your
based money like these can happen really
easily and because imports are
transitive things can like things can
pile up into that pile of trash the
solution we found for this that I think
is a also very powerful pattern are
forbidden dependency tests so forbidden
dependency tests are way to sort that
for example your base bundle does not
depend on any UI let's take a concrete
example so for example in an react every
every component needs to inherit from
react component so if you want that you
know UI at all can even your base bundle
you simply add that one test saying
react component is not the transitive
dependency of a base bundle and it will
just fail right so looking at the graph
again you know you just get a test
failure when someone tries to add the
date picker and it's typically like in
that case it's usually really easy to
fix it right away because probably that
person didn't actually want to put it
there which is some weird transitive
dependency but if you're like two years
in and it's been there for a while it's
typically super hard to get the stuff
disentangle so the test really helps you
alright
ideally though you find like that most
natural pass right you want to get to a
state where whatever the engineers and
your teams do the most straightforward
way to do something is the right way
right so that they don't get off the
pass they naturally do the right things
and then as I just showed with the
Forbidden depends it has you know just
add a test and I think this is also
something that not many people feel
empowered to do so please feel empowered
to add tests to your application that
ensure the major and variant of your
infrastructure right the tests are not
only for you know testing that your mass
function does the right things right
they're also for infrastructure and for
the major like design features of
application so please do that and I try
to avoid human judgment outside of the
application domain I
so if you work on an application we have
to understand the the business part but
not every engineer in your organization
can and will understand how cost
building work and they don't need to do
that right so try to introduce these
things in your application in a way that
it's completely fine you can still work
well without having that knowledge and
and all that complexity in your head and
then also really just make it easy to
lead code so my talk was called
designing very large JavaScript
application maybe the web best advice I
can give is that you should ideally not
get to this very large stage the best
way to not get there is that you delete
stuff before it's too late
cool I want to address just one more
point which is people sometimes say that
having no abstractions at all it's
better than having the wrong wrong
abstraction right what this really means
is that the costs of the wrong
abstractions is very high so be careful
I think this is sometimes misinterpreted
it does not mean that you should have no
abstractions again it just means that
you have to be very careful and so I
think my main advice is to get good at
making the right choices right and as I
was saying at the start of the
presentation the way to get there is to
think with your engineers on your team
how they will use your API and how they
will use your abstractions you can get
there with experience it will take you a
while I have done this wrong most of the
time and I still do but I think I'm
still getting better and so empathy and
experience the way how you can lead have
the right abstractions in your
application thank you very much
[Applause]
you